-Our next guest is
a four-time Olympian,
Olympic Gold medalist,
World Cup champion,
and the most decorated
female skier of all time.
Her memoir, "Rise: My Story,"
is on sale now.
Please welcome back to the show
our friend, Lindsey Vonn.
How are you, Lindsey?
-Hey, Seth, I'm good.
How are you?
-I'm wonderful.
I'm very sorry we can't
be doing this in person.
I do hope next time
that is the case.
Congratulations on the book.
I want to ask you about that,
but I feel like
there's something
even more important
to congratulate you on.
You went on vacation,
a ski vacation,
which I think people would
assume you do all the time,
but you wrote that it was
the first ski vacation
since you were 9 years old.
-Yeah, I'm pretty pumped
about it.
It was better than I expected.
You know, when I was 9,
I didn't do après-ski,
so I felt like I --
I crushed the après-ski
this time around,
and it was a much more
entertaining experience
than what I remember
when I was 9.
-Now, a couple of questions.
You were skiing
with some friends.
Do you have to, like,
let up a little bit
when you're Lindsey Vonn out
with some civilians
on their skis?
-I usually let them have, like,
a little bit of a head start,
and then, when they're about
three-quarters of the way down,
then I'll try to catch up,
and usually,
I'll still end up waiting
for them at the lift. [ Laughs ]
-Now, how many people
on the slopes --
'Cause I imagine if you see
Lindsey Vonn on the ski slope,
you probably think
you're hallucinating.
Do people clock you
when they're next to you
on the ski slopes?
-I've definitely gotten
some interesting comments.
I think most of the time,
you know,
they have their heads turned,
and they're like,
"What?
What's going on here?"
And I try to ski a bit incognito
so no one --
I try not to, you know, draw
too much attention to myself.
But I definitely catch
the attention of the ski patrol,
and generally
they're chasing after me,
trying to pull my pass.
[ Laughs ]
-[ Laughs ]
I want to also ask
about the fact
that the Olympics are coming up,
and I'm wondering,
when it's right
around the corner like this,
do you feel relief
to not be competing,
or do you feel nostalgia
for all the years that you did?
-I definitely have
a bit of FOMO.
I wish that I was racing,
but at the same time,
I think, right now, with COVID,
everything is so different and
there's so many new challenges
that I definitely
am not envious of that.
But I do miss the competition.
And, you know, the Olympics
are always so special.
You know, the opening ceremonies
and -- and just
the whole experience in general.
I'm definitely
going to be jealous,
but I'm excited
to cheer on my teammates,
my former teammates, and
all of the Team USA athletes.
It's going to be fun to watch.
-Now, I can't quite remember
where skiing falls
in the winter Olympics,
but did you --
after you competed,
did you have a few days
to just enjoy yourself
when you were there,
or was it right at the tail end?
-No, I actually
never have had a chance
to celebrate after the Olympics.
It's usually straight back
into competition.
And I think when I won, I think
I had one glass of champagne,
and then I had a race
the next day.
So there is literally
no celebration
until the end of the season,
which was March,
and that's definitely
anticlimactic.
But I -- you know,
I'll definitely be celebrating
for the athletes
this time around.
-All right.
I can't imagine --
I don't think it's easy
to go on a book tour,
but I do want
to stress to you --
and I've met a lot of authors --
you can drink all the way
through your book tour.
Please don't wait
till the very end
and just have
one glass of champagne.
-Okay, okay.
Great advice, Seth.
I'll take your word for it.
I'll definitely try that.
-A lot of authors
are, like, famous drunks.
You could even go --
just go on, go for it.
-Well, I mean, it's just --
-You've got
a lot of catching up to do.
-I got après-ski, and I got the,
you know, book tour.
Is there a term for, like,
drinking on book tours?
-We're going to come up
with one.
Yeah, like, après-livre.
I think that's -- livre,
like the French -- après--
We'll figure it out.
But I want to ask --
-That sounds fancy.
That sounds fancy.
-You -- [ Laughs ]
Just book beers.
How about book beers?
-[ Laughs ] Sounds great.
Let's have some book beers.
-There you go.
So you -- you wrote your book,
and then you actually decided
to go back
and rework a fair amount of it.
And I would imagine --
I'm surprised that doesn't
happen more often.
You're writing about your life,
and then when it's finally
on the page and, you know,
it has a sense
of being the permanent record,
you must have --
It's in that moment
that you must think,
"Wait, this isn't quite right."
What did you have to go back
and sort of rework
before it was ready to go?
-Pretty much everything.
You know, when I was writing it,
I was still kind of
closing out my career,
and then, you know,
right after I retired,
I was just in
a really weird spot.
You know, I was definitely
a bit depressed,
and I, you know, had a bit of
resentment that I had to retire
because I would have loved
to keep going.
I just physically couldn't do it
anymore with all of my injuries.
So I just -- The tone
of the book wasn't right,
and I wanted it to be
really inspirational.
I wanted it to be, you know,
motivating to others
who also faced adversity.
So I literally scrapped
the whole thing
and started it completely over.
And now I'm really happy
with the result.
I think it was
the right decision.
-I have one last thing
I want to ask you about,
which is very cool, as well --
not just an author,
but you also co-directed a film
about one of your heroes,
Olympic skier Picabo Street.
How did that come about,
and what was it about her
that you wanted to --
to make a film?
-I mean, Picabo has such
an amazing story,
and I think people know
quite a bit about her
because she was so successful,
and that's one of the reasons
why she was my idol growing up.
But it was such an honor
to be able to direct
and produce this film
with Frank Marshall.
I mean, he's such
a legend in film.
So now everyone will know
all that I know about Picabo.
And, yeah,
she's just such a legend,
so it was just truly an honor.
-Now, I would imagine you --
when you spoke to her
or when you speak to her,
you always say,
"You were my hero.
I watched you growing up."
Are there Olympic athletes
who have started
saying that to you yet, Lindsey?
Has that moment come?
-Yeah, you know, I'm not
that young anymore, Seth,
so that time has
definitely come, come and gone.
But I think the person that's
had the most impact on me
was Sofia Goggia,
who actually won the last
Olympic downhill in Pyeongchang,
and I obviously was
in those Olympics with her.
And she's always said
since the beginning
that I was her idol,
which is a little bit weird
'cause we're not
that far apart in age,
but it was -- it was
really meaningful to me,
and she still asked me
for advice.
And, you know, she's obviously
still at the top of her game.
She's won every single downhill
this year.
So to have someone like that,
you know, still having me
as their idol
is very, very meaningful to me.
-Well, it's very well deserved.
Thank you so much
for being here.
Congratulations on the book
and the film
and the incredible career.
I hope next time,
I see you in person.
-Definitely.
Thanks, Seth.
Have some book beers for me.
-[ Laughs ] Will do.
"Rise: My Story" is on sale now
wherever you buy your books,
but please support local
and independent bookstores.
We'll be right back
with more "Late Night."